don't you hit you yeah so all right so
uh pitter
all right
when i hit her
she came back around
and i can hear her accelerate
and she hit me
she came back she almost hit
uh christy
came back as i was
slowing down from the pit trying to get
out of the way
i mean full force
she sped up
i got it all right okay though i'm good
bro you need to be checked out no i'm
good
[Music]
[Music]
i'm trying to get those strips
dude i'm talking
when i called you
i saw the car
dip over and i'm like damn that car's
moving fast
and i hit front radar
um
we were in the slow lane i had a gap
that's where
yeah um i had a gap there was no traffic
and i mean she was
all over the place so
um i had a clear
pretty much clear highway
so i moved in and i pitted her right on
on the passenger side
it was a good clean pit
as soon as i slowed down to get
out of traffic she literally came around
and sped up and just slammed into the
asset of me
when she's still moving from like the
pit
and just hit you or do you think she was
back on the gas in this intention she
was back on the gas because when i when
i hit her
she was she was still pushing the gas as
she was going through that pit okay
cool you got johnny with your partner
i should have mine in here if you give
me in just a second i just grabbed it
i should have memorized
oh okay yeah i'm good brother
like i said everything was good up until
she uh
until she smacked me right in the ass
yeah you called him off and i literally
was going up to the 22 to meet him and i
see this this car
in the middle lane
slide over into the slow lane jets
around the car and i'm like i'm looking
down and i'm like damn i'm still going
like 100 and she's pulling away from me
so i hit front radar and i had her at
what i said 107 108.
and i was like
so i caught up as soon as i lit her up
dude she all
right over in the road
based on what he uh the complainant said
i thought she was long gone yeah that's
what i said he was giving he gave us a
bad call out at some point
because y'all would have had it faster
either or we were way ahead we were way
ahead
because when uh when when
whoever said
she's probably at the 16 by now i was
still on the overpass and i got
owned at that point
i knew she hadn't made it that far me
and christy were waiting there
and
nobody passed it i i just yeah i mostly
got the billy
you called him off i had every intention
of just meeting him to give him the
laser to take back to the office
here we go i figured based on that i
mean at the 16.
yeah exactly i mean
and me and christy were up there and we
were we already had what 22 when you
called us
who was on the radio for what i've seen
during this whole
thing you were trying to no i mean
dispatcher i don't have a clue
they got two
he was doing too much i'm like there
ain't no way he's calling this
because she was like 96 where are you at
96 where yeah and i'm like he's got two
hands he's going across three lanes
right now
that's how
christy
unfortunately was silent
so i think what it is is whenever you
pitted her she just rolled she did
cause that damage on the side of her car
she just rolled she didn't shoot over
how fast would y'all run about 80 90.
probably like 85.
[Music]
turn all your shit off